est à venir max gallo le pire est
toujours sur le pire est sûre comme vous
êtes quelqu'un de cultivé d'intelligent
de briand bien sûr on va vous faire
l'interview nul lumière sinon plein ne
bouge pas dans la jungle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo bon là je dois dire ah ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui se maîtrisent parfaitement
ma croyable il n'a pas cillé
pendant leurs carcasses comme ça ils
mobile dont total reste déjà taillé
total respect du bon l'interview nul n'a
été un nul alors est ce que vous
préférez c on commence avec ce sur quoi
c'est toujours des choix c'est votre
surnom alors est ce que vous préférez
quand on vous appelle le malraux des
campings ou le michener d'hypermarchés
cette équivalence peut-être le mal rôde
et camping préféré le malheureux des
gens bien dormir sous la tente très bien
là tu dois dire un truc normalement
alors il le dit mais est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père votre mère la mère
jusqu'à 14 ans le père après la bonne
réponse vous préférez hitler ou staline
est ce que je préfère mourir dans une
chambre à gaz ou dans un chaudron
ouais je sais pas donc c'est une des
formes de morges peut pas choisir entre
méforme de mort est-ce que vous
préféreriez on se concentre je me
concentre tout ferrari est réincarné en
françois hollande ou en jacques toubon
au jeu préférant mode la mort définitive
ouais là il faut choisir faut choisir
françois hollande
attention cependant il n'est pas tendre
avec vous françois hollande il est pas
tendre avec moi mais je l' ai vu naître
à la politique
ouais car le hasard fait les choses
quand j'ai été porte parole du
gouvernement il était mon directeur de
cabinet à huy donc j'ai vu tout petit en
culottes courtes mais il dit des choses
sur vous terrible il dit qu' à l'époque
vous combattiez médecin à nice et que
maintenant vous retrouver du côté de
marchiani a eu lundi sa wii d'accord
vous préférez voulait toujours être
incarnée en françois hollande s'il faut
choisir oui sinon chez présidence de
cette question parce que tout bon
personne on veut choisir tout bon pour
la trouille quand même ça fout tu me
diras mais pourquoi être réincarné c'est
surtout salou est là alors est ce que
vous auriez plus de dix ans vous
donneriez plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles ou
un vieux puisqu'il échappe sur des
jeunes
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles
pour leur piquer leur sac à main qu'elle
sorte de la poste et car pension 1 ou un
vieux qui se tape des jeunes le vieux
qui le vieux qui stoppe des jeunes avant
d'accord et je suis vieux déjà oui chez
vous savez que c'est agréable
alors le mot le plus con pour vous en
amour c'est merci encore oui-oui ou
combien tu peux nous merci merci merci
merci mot stupide
un amour sont tombés est-ce que vous
préféreriez être coincés dans un
ascenseur avec bernard henri lévy ou
philippe sollers
[Applaudissements]
vous voudriez être guillotiné ou pendus
guillotiné disons alors allons-y
guillotine est ce à cause du bouquin
parce que vous êtes dedans et guillotiné
c'est plus rapide sur un s'il faut
choisir je dis pas parce que oui c'est
plus propre d'une certaine manière oui
les pendus encore il fera encore d'une
taille respectable même si il ya des
chevaliers sans tête pour me bouge pas
par le jingle
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
à
la bouger les choses et non il n'a pas
bougé il à manger bouger les moustaches
n'a pas aussi bien alors intervenu là je
vous préviens ce que vous préférez
staline ou hitler
la question c'est vraiment rude comme
questionnant insérée dans
mais c'est mort ou vif est-ce que vous
avez votre carte mère c'était je vous ai
dit alors attendez je les avertis celle
intervenue la ligne ça dépend des jours
et entre mon père ou ma mère vous
préférez qui le fit sortie si vous êtes
déjà mangé du surgelé dans un igloo non
est-ce que vos vêtements vous les
préférez d'étain rétrécit me déchirait
alors bad et en priorité
on monte on ne dit pas les fringues pas
la famille jeux et consoles
concentrez vous quel est d'après vous
l'animal qui embrasse le mieux sommes
bien bonne on sait pas alors maintenant
à un dilemme c'est compliqué un ami
débarque chez vous à l'improviste
qu'est ce qui vous gêne le plus qu'ils
trouvent sur votre table de nuit
mein kampf ou un godemiché mein kampf à
lui dans le larzac et en même temps ils
sont encore à montredon du larzac quand
même serré pas pu faire la même règle
[Rires]
parce qu'elles souffrent pas trop ce que
tu imites là une question que ces deux
amis ont pesé lundi sur comédie un
chauffeur vous êtes chauffeur routier
vous êtes mais j'ai la chance de
fréquenter un vous êtes chauffeurs
routiers vous perdez le contrôle de
votre véhicule et une grande descente et
vous écrasé sur une maison ou sur une
autre
d'un côté il ya votre maison avec votre
femme et vos enfants et l'autre côté il
ya une école primaire
vous vous écrasez sur quoi c'est idiot
non je sais pas qui est ce qu'à monter
c'est quand même une fonction celle là
je sais qu'il a inventé moi je saute
avant comme ça j'ai pas réfléchir
ah oui d'accord on allume serge par jour
maintenant on va faire une interview
null null on bouge pas
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon vous vous arbitraire janvier
stéphane d'accord la mauvaise idée que
maintenant vous m'avez connais ça dans
le cigare êtes vous appelez janvier
stéphane pour toute la vie bien alors
roger vous êtes prêts interview nul
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère ma mère à wemmel dit
carrément j'adorais mon père mais vous
je préférais ma mère c'est bien un petit
d'alger il aime bien ce moment là dans
le sud c'est un peu comme ça non oui je
le sais très sud ça vous préfériez
staline ou hitler staline staline
pourquoi parce qu'il a tué plus de gens
j'avoue que je ne crois pas qu'il
détruit plus de gens là je vais le faire
dans un peu mon sens de l'humour et que
j'espère bien qu'on veut c'est
monstrueux staline donc on veut et
allons dit il ya donc qui a dévoyé le
dépôt idéal qui l'idéal communiste mais
maintenant je sais que c'est la mode de
2,2 comparé les communistes et les nazis
et moi c'est pas mon sentiment
d'accord oui c'est vrai qu'on compare on
dit a eu deux totalitarismes au 20e
siècle
il ya eu l'hitlérisme stalinisme et
c'est vrai qu'on a on les compare vous
pensez que c'est pas comparable non non
non parce que je me suis fait accrocher
une fois dans une émission on m'a dit
mais comment osez vous dire que vous
êtes communiste est d abord ne me parle
pas sûr sont là sinon je paie d'avril et
comprendra non plus pourquoi pas nazi 1
j'ai dit mais moi je vais vous dire
pourquoi pas ce que je peux vous résumer
l'idéal communiste
l'idéal communiste justice et partage
maintenant vous définissez moi l'idéal
nazis déplacement l'idéal nazis et
voyons si ça se confondrait qu'au début
l'idée communiste était une plus belle
idée que l'idée nationale socialiste je
trouve c'est de le reconnaître c'est
vrai alors est-ce que vous préféreriez
faire l'amour avec une fille très laide
ou un mec très beau ils filtrent et loeb
à hilla incorrigible c'est vraiment
macho man est-ce que vous avez plus de
circoncis vous donner plus de
circonstances atténuantes à des vieux
qui se tape des jeunes ou à des jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieux plutôt des
jeunes qui stoppe des vieux parce que je
trouve cette hausse in de générosité
extraordinaire
ouais non j'avais dit des jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux jeux c'est bien
mais c'est contré dans votre bouquin
dans le bouquin de roger dentelle
effectivement aurélie elle veut 70 ans à
ben [ __ ] très vieux qui tapent sur des
jeunes est d'accord parce que sont bons
ils ont fini leur vie sont deux des
tarés bien roger évoqué d'un book est un
spécialiste
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore oui oui le plus qu'on le lui
qu'on sait c'est oui oui oui oui vous
avez compris moi dit oui alors la bombe
atomique arrive dans 5 minutes vous
faites quoi
bah je je je me louer au prix des cinq
minutes que ce que je peux faire toutes
façons tu n'as pas le temps d'y aller la
celi rami c'est en fleur en même temps
ouais ou alors tout seul
votre partenaire n'est pas très excité
vous lui demandez comment il s'appelle
vous lui faites un truc spécial où vous
vous cassez en claquant la porte
je crois que je pars sans claquer la
porte
bien élevé non parce que d'abord ça ne
change rien et on se diminue on est en
bio loin vous croyez j'aurais s'agissait
ya 20 ans il ya vingt ans vous auriez
dit quoi le truc spécial le oui je veux
bien si vous étiez mort vous voudriez
être réincarné en quoi attention on
edouard balladur en giscard d'estaing ou
en pierre messmer empire messmer en
pierre mais cela oui parce que c'était
un projet pas ses idées politiques
et c'est un héros il a une belle gueule
et il a il a parlé net et puis là
pendant la guerre il était très très
bien conduit oui c'est vrai on vous
applaudir c'est une très bonne ambiance
pas tant dans le jingle vous le savez ça
à pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
génial parce qu il bouge vraiment pas
quoi je peux pas m'empêcher de sourire
en regardant lui bouche vraiment pas à
vous êtes joueur bien alors l'interview
nul donc chez les questions les plus
cons possible et les réponses des
personnes possible on va voir
est-ce que ça c'est la question la
première question c'est la question qui
nous a été donnée par clotilde courau
qui désormais est une amie salut
clotilde est ce que par amour vous
embrasse seriez sans fois de suite des
chaussettes sales jeunes marc amour oui
oui par amour iv va écouter malgré tout
l'amour que je pourrais avoir pour une
dame je ne supporterais pas qu'elle soit
salle donc je ne pourrais pas embrasser
de manquer ses chaussettes sales et vous
vous le feriez marion non parce que je
veux pas que claudie j'ai peur quelques
côtes il de kuroky fasse ce genre de
truc je pourrais le faire si aussi là le
propriétaire des chaussettes est parti
depuis très longtemps à voilà assez beau
cette fille chasse du fait de jolis vous
posez la question c'est un petit geste
par un petit peu ah merde j'ai posé
toutes les questions sauf fétiche ou
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père
votre mère je vais vous dire très
sincèrement ce propos tellement con
comme question 16 ans est très content
parce que moi je suis incapable de
répondre aussi pas si je vais pas me
répondre si si si il se trouve que ma
mère a été j'avais cinq ans quand elle
est tombée malade et donc j'ai toujours
vu une personne aux lits acquis à la fin
je faisais ces piqûre de morphine
ouais donc c'est vrai que la personne
vivante avec moi celui qui m'a vraiment
éduquer c'est mon père ouais et donc
finalement je pourrais dire que j'aimais
plus mon père que ma mère même si ça
paraît comme ça normal parce que c'était
une personne vivante alors que j'avais
en face de moi gamin une personne
uniquement malades qui était ma maman
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
alors il ya un grand débat vous savez
que anconina qui se dit pas tomber si on
préfère en général dire qu'on préfère
staline parce que l'idée communiste way
est une idée généreuse avec les néo
nazis ne l'est pas
c'est ce qu'on dira jamais assez ce
qu'on dit moi personnellement je trouve
sur deux monstres absolument trigo
il n'y a aucune différence quoi selon
les aveux c'est vraiment laissé des
frères jumeaux mais ma préférence à
vraiment hitler ou staline
moi je déteste plus hitler parce
qu'effectivement il cette idée d'
éradiquée de la surface de la terre des
gens parce qu'ils sont d'une religion
d'une origine les juifs les tziganes ou
les homosexuels mais staline
on peut lui en vouloir peut-être autant
parce qu'il a trahi une belle idée ouais
il la tue quand même outre battu est
sauvé est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en christophe dechavanne
nagui ou arthur
écoutez je pense de lui quelques
difficultés actuellement donc je tiens
absolument à murray me réincarner en
nagui oui bon voilà assez gentil ces
chrétiens parce que certains parce que
c'est mon producteur
ouais je sais que c'est le meilleur
coach que j'ai eu ma garde côtes nous
sommes repartis avec des bêtises de
monsieur pierre je n'avais pas fait de
prime time depuis 86 ouais bon donc il
me fallait quelqu'un qui murray après il
me donne la pêche
comment un ministre et ça a été un coach
absolument extraordinaire donc c'est
bien le dire en tous les cas chez moi
j'aimerais bien tagi quel est votre
punition préférez vous préférez être
passé mort du piqué au vif est mort
d'une mort du pain c'est piqué ou griffé
à la morsure dans l'amour ça existe il
est choqué on
oui mais je dirais qu'il fasse le plus
mal qu as tu sont horriblement mal et
pourtant c'est un temps il est chaud le
bien est ce que vous préféreriez pendant
dix ans c'est une vue de l'esprit bien
sûr pas de sexe ou pas mangé pendant dix
ans elle en disant pas de sexe pas
manger c'est une façon de vous demander
je préférais baiser au bout fait en gros
bah je pense quand même que pour pour
partir sur dix ans d'abord comme ava
creux on va forcément crever si range
part il faut quand même choisir de ne
pas se taper qui compte c'est le
problème est d'accord mais si vous êtes
tout seul et je veux bien être robinson
crusoé soit supportable et enfin
vendredi arriver là quand même on se
frotte à vous êtes d'accord
alors bon vous préféreriez être aveugle
et sourd ou amputé des bras et des
jambes
non non c'est loin des cotonnades etc et
sur la con aveugle et sourd ou alors
amputé honda et ben c'est quand même
amputé des bras et des jambes parce que
aveugle et sourd c'est quelque chose que
je vous porter un slip un caleçon ou
rien un slip c'est très important
on se demande dès fois à quoi ça tient
le service public là on le sait mais oui
voilà je vous pouvez vous donner
également des mâles même marqué suisse
très bonne marque suisse
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
l'animal qui embrasse le mieux j'ai
horreur de me faire embrasser par les
animaux ah bon j'ai pas du tout jeune or
pas du tout assez marrant c'est un peu
comme marion cotillard alors j'adore
j'adore me faire masser par qui on
voudra mais paparazzi bord la dernière
question pierre bellemare comment
vendriez vous un vibromasseur qui se
recharge sur l'allume-cigare je
commencerai par dire
share and we l'objet que je vais vous
tendre à doit absolument être utilisée
sur un parking et en aucun cas pendant
la marche du véhicule en effet à partir
du moment où vous avez branché saïgas le
vibromasseur que je vais battre vous
proposer tout est possible le nirvana
peut arriver et donc il est impossible
de jouir de nirvana cyr en même temps
est en train de doubler nos deux chaînes
de 2,9 sur le dos bravo version
28 ans comme vous êtes en train de
devenir une star
il faut s'habituer on va vous poser des
questions on va poser des questions cons
parce que on va poser toutes les
questions un peu imbécile comme celle
que vient de poser en tombe sur donc on
bouge quand jean yole albert moux
janvier
ce soir bien
alors comment vous êtes prêts à les
proposer une première question qui est
la question dit clotilde courau c'est
une question qui a été inventé par
clotilde courau est ce que par amour
vous embrasse seriez sans fois de suite
des chaussettes sales
non non et vous daniel o moi je respecte
pas les questions aussi conclu d'accord
ça s'appelle l'interview nul mais on
peut dire nulles et qu'on a bien sûr
alors maintenant la question la question
qu'il est magnifique parce qu'il a dit
thomas la question en moins la question
pierre bellemare comment vendriez vous
un vibromasseur qui se branche sur
l'allume-cigare frédéric diefenthal
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] fume pas
encore
enfin la réponse serait non seulement la
demande de monsieur prévost je suis
marié je sais ça fait trois fois bien
elles sont allées à samson est ce que
vous préféreriez vous réincarner écoutez
bien en lara fabian en céline dion ou
ans hélène ségara qui pas lara fabian
non je sens que tu envie de dire ça je
n'en ai pas bien aller alors ça union
avis bien ces lignes on à céline dion
tabac je sais bien ces lignes d'eau quel
est votre émission préférée vous
préférez être privé de sexe ou privés de
câlins privé 500 j'aime aucune de ces
pays non mais vous êtes attendait cet
objet ou le privé de sexe privé de lara
fabian
privé de sexe se priver de câlins que si
vous préférez sexe privé de sexe afp
okala parce qu'avec les câlins je me dis
que ça va quoi évidemment bon ça peut le
faire c'est vrai donc finalement j'avais
de quel est le mot le plus quand on
amour pour vous merci encore oui-oui ou
leur race à viande
oui fabien non oui oui vous pensez
frédéric diefenthal que pour réussir à
la télé il faut être une ordure un
pourri ou un [ __ ] points
je crois qu'avec un peu des trois ça
peut marcher moi vous avez fait de la
télé il a répondu j'ai pas réussi pour a
terminé sur une question de culture
politique l'esprit nous citer les quatre
prétendants de l'opposition pour la
mairie de paris
athos porthos et aramis et l'autre c'est
comment des gens là c'est dur c'est dur
ça quels sont les quatre prétendants
balladur oui très bien je suis soufflé
pas souffle pas m'at on ne souffle pas
dieu
après corde et un bon faut trois
rivières au cas où il en manque 3
il a dit quelque chose mais écoute mais
compagne et leprévost ses rivaux lui
connaissait pas non je jeûne on
attendait ça n'a aucune importance je
sais simplement pour montrer que
finalement tout le monde s'en fout ce
truc là à dire que la presse en parle
toute la journée
la télé entend toute la journée la radio
par toute la journée et tout le monde
s'en fout la preuve c'est même pas si
c'est important de le savoir fric c'est
la honte aussi vous allez répondre
olivier savait trop dit ou pas assez
gains séguin séguin oui tiberi tiberi
oui balladur et pour l'opposition le
ghana il y en a quatre
mais la position séguin à la fia
oh
non
genzyme est encore plus étonné que quand
il conduit son taxi dans le film c'est
du sauvage découlent et sa télévision de
l'an 2000 c'est le troisième
[Musique]
bien alors l'interview nul vous allez
voir c'est très très con c'est normal ça
s'appelle comme ça donc sinon ça
s'appellerait pas l'interview nul voila
est-ce que vous préfériez d'hitler ou
staline gens préfèrent aucun mais on
compare pas donc il fallait choisir je
choisirais certainement pas hitler
d'accord aujourd'hui à manama
non mais attends la dialectique la
mecque à l'âge de 14 ans elle est déjà
dans le coup un temps fort de ce lien
il est au courant alors tiens voilà
imaginez que vous croyez la
réincarnation vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en giscard balladur ou
raymond barre terry a maintenant vous
êtes amis de tiberi je préfère pas être
un cas non non je vais pas me répondre
ça à chaque fois c'est l'interview est
composé de giscard giscard balladur ou
bar voilà c'est un jeu ça va parce que
balla diop à ce que moi je ferais rire
les gens ah oui d'accord sympa ce bien
est ce que vous donnez plus de
circonstances atténuantes écoutez bien
les compliquée celle là à à des vieux
qui se tape des jeunes ou à des jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieux et des jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieux way où ils ont
pu se concentrer en nord - à moins que
sa croissance est énorme ah ouais non
c'est vrai qu'ils ont versé la question
accord donc il vaut mieux être un vieux
qui se tape des jeunes 15 jeunes qui
tapent sur un vieux d'accord entre pas
de sexe et pas mangé pendant dix ans
vous choisiriez quoi compliquer
compliqué le camarade sexe parce que si
vous mangez pas pendant dix ans toute
manière il n'y a pas de section
dialectique dialectique toujours alors
imaginez qu'on soit aux sports d'hiver
tous les deux dans un chalet bloqués par
la neige
moi je meurs de faim on n'a plus rien à
manger je meurs de faim et vous vous
avec moi à manger vous commencez par
quoi le cerveau le crb on dirait pas
pourquoi pour moi non le cerveau le
cerveau alors bon il est obligé de
partir sur une île déserte alain krivine
vous préféreriez partir avec un mec très
beau une fille très laide fusionne avec
très beau une fille très loin c'est pour
y rester de l'ombre une fuite relève
allez quand même vous n'êtes pas du tout
que l'habituelle salle du tout dit mais
ce n'est pas une injure du tout du tout
pour moi dakar non mais pour moi non
plus alors un ami débarque à
l'improviste chez vous ce qui vous
ferait le plus au monde qui découvre sur
l'étape de nuit
le livre de claire chazal ou un
godemichet
il y en a qui est un outil de plaisir
parait-il et l'autre qui est bon enfin
bref donc oui non plus plutôt le livre
de claire chazal vous préfériez qui voit
le livre de claire chazal quelques du
nord qui voit plutôt le godemichet alors
on va voir si vous avez bon coeur est-ce
que vous échangeriez votre paralysie
générale vous serez paralyser toute
votre vie pour qu'ils aient plus de
famine en ethiopie je dirais non parce
que je le resterai mensonger way dont
j'ai là non je me battrais pour qu'il y
ait plus de familles en ethiopie pour ça
faut pas de calais paralysés tout faire
il faut pas être paralytique pour
empêcher la famine pour battre tu sens
le mec a discuté avec section
[Applaudissements]
bon évidemment vous n'avez pas bougé par
an le jingle et je vous en félicite
vous savez que c'est la chose la plus
importante pour moi dans cette émission
donc c'est pas les questions nul de
d'habitude j'ai bossé cet été moi j'ai
pas j'ai bossé jamais préparé des
nouvelles halles à ce que je vous ai vu
dans les journaux en vacances bah non
c'est dévié puis il faut maintenant j'ai
vraiment bossé parce qu'avant je vous
disais vous préférez votre père ou votre
mère hitler ou staline c'est pas du tout
si jamais je venais à l'extrait qu'on
vient de voir
oui aurait inspiré la question s'il
n'avait pas déjà trouvé une vraie
différence d'âge entre votre coupe de
cheveux votre coiffure dans l'extrait
convient de voir est aujourd'hui la
première question que je suis une femme
vous vous laver les cheveux tous les
combien tous les jours adacore je fais
maintenant tous les jours toujours avant
j'étais raplapla un objet pareil dit
c'était un peu gras mouillé la wii sur
l'extrait c'est normal ou à oui vous
êtes en skiant sur scène oui mais voilà
vous êtes vous donne rarement oui
franchement moi je fais un compliment en
forme
ah oui je vous ai rarement vu aussi chic
aussi à six prov
ainsi me trotte disons tous non très
bien le succès vous va bien
alors est ce que vous préférez attention
c'est assez compliqué est ce que vous
préférez un président de la république
d'extrême droite élu au suffrage
universel ou pas d'élection du tout pas
d'élections dites pas d'élection du tout
fait pour la dictature à ce moment là
complètement ça reviendra au même score
comme midi quelle différence y at-il
entre frédéric françois et françois
valéry à cela les durs je reconnais qu
il faut vraiment il faut vraiment des
gens mois d'été
ils sont toujours là alors alors est ce
que vous aimeriez avoir années
supplémentaires 1 heure supplémentaire
un doigt un sexe et si c'était un chèque
supplémentaire lequel le sexe de mon
amant gaza
ouais bonne réponse et comme les
escargots comme ça on reste ils se font
pas chier les escargots vins une idée
même un watt tu vois le bras d'honneur
confrères gonzesses on aura un sexe de
femme pas loin juste là internet
puissent quitter l'église
bien qu est ce que tu fais ben tu vois
je baise
michel et fring vandry de la drogue la
sortie des écoles si la survie de vos
enfants dépendent et c'est idiot c'est
la chance d'étudier les monstrueuses
s'appelle interview c'est le choix de
sophie ça c'est exactement ce dont
classé au bon niveau ce que je suis mais
loin de tout ça moi je pense je prends
un passeport et je me casse loin de ce
monde pourri non mais tu peux dollar
évidemment tu peux pas de barre et à la
question si tu veux pas d'argent mais je
peux d'accord est-ce que c'est nul je
paie ouais bon si vous en aviez le
pouvoir ou mettriez vous parie sur la
carte de france à paris à paris les
services il pleut toujours et c'est
certainement ce qui fait sa vie en panne
on sait bien c'est super moi je crois je
passe à un moment merveilleux des contes
toi tu t'en fous c'est pas toi qui a
réussi si je reprends la fin de la
conversation c'est vrai que tu fait beau
on est content
c'est un peu d'écho à ce qu'on a eu
c'est en tant qu elle était pourri j'ai
essayé de faire de la concurrence à tf1
la ménagère choix pour la tient à la
gorge
[Applaudissements]
chez lui
la dramatisation
tiens c'est quoi ça vous êtes devenu
macho brandela commandant pas du tout
match au non non c'est simplement plaire
mais qu'est ce que ça va être des coûts
la différence entre hétéros et match on
joue encore bas hétéro c'est un match
sympa et un match au sommet terreau
qu'on bon si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex-shop vous seriez quoi comme objet
mois et ont porté le parti allait mieux
que bien à elle vibre
commence à vibrer bon dernière question
est bon vous l'image de l'image la plus
triste une veuve à sa fenêtre un chien
perdu sur une autoroute ou un dimanche
devant la télé une veuve à sa fenêtre
non triste c'est que j'avance et
dimanche devant le tu peux dormir donc
tu oublies c'était pour sa cave à sa
fenêtre
howe est terrible ça de perdre son mari
et d'avoir pas de fenêtre ça sera encore
via des moteurs ils veulent qui a été
celle d'apple à une fenêtre c'est vrai
qu'elle peut regarder la vie et se dire
que c'est possible de sauter
[Applaudissements]
jean-marie attendu par les deux d'elisa
zylberstein oui tu vas arriver et dans
lautrec le merveilleux film de roger
planchon il ya cette phrase merveilleuse
ou 4 la fille se fait découper en
tranches et tout est dit tu veux
médecins en images lui dit son frère et
lui dit non pas de pathétique en
peinture la cruauté tranquille du
quotidien suffit pas voilà la veuve à sa
fenêtre merci jean marie bigard à la
bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien donc on va faire l'interview nul de
toute façon est ce que vous connaissez
clotilde courau kotil de kuro il ya une
question maintenant qui s'appelle la
question clotilde courau et je vous la
pose mais entendu est-ce que vous
embrasse seriez par amour
cent fois une paire de chaussettes sales
de dany boon non vous le feriez pas à
vous ça non non non vous n'êtes pas
comme côté de pau est ce que vous
préférez votre père ou votre mère c'est
l'interview ne l'a jamais c'est ce que
tu aimerais mieux rouler une pelle à ta
mère au cou shake ton ferme si vous vous
améliorez la question les deux les deux
d'accord au sujet en page accepte les
deux là est-ce que vous accorde riez
plus de circonstances atténuantes à un
vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles mais
pourquoi faudrait-il qu'ils les
circonstances atténuantes bas parce que
un vieux qui se tape des petites
oui ça vous gêne pas rouler mieux oui
c'est vrai qu'ils se taper une petite
jeune ou pas sur les vieilles attend
hors de question qu'un jeune sur une
vieille vous préférez les vieux qui se
tape des heures si elles sont
consentantes
cette question est ce que vous préfériez
faire l'amour avec un mec très laid ou
une fille très belle une fille très
belle puis très bien est ce que votre
fesci est ce que bourran et un ami qui
rendent chez vous la nuit dans votre
chambre et vous un copain ou non pas du
tout est ce que vous auriez plus honte
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de
chevet le livre de claire chazal ou un
godemiché un godemichet ça vous ferait
plus sombre que le livre de personnes
enfin ont tassé
un sentiment ouais parce que j'en ai à
[ __ ]
ni l'un ni l'autre fin août mois au
dessus des toits rôle et vous quel est
votre punition préféré être dans ces
mordus ou pique et pince mardi a mordu
s'agit vous aimez bien que mort d ouais
mais on note
j'étais là c'est tout et là tout est
noté tout est enregistré sur bande
est-ce que alors maintenant deux
sérieusement dany boon il a une patte
d'une sexuelle une hypothèse évidemment
la cua une panne sexuelle
peut-être à besançon les habillages et
fatigué peut-être alors il ya une panne
sexuelle un jour je m'étonnerai avec
vous qu'on puisse avoir des pannes
sexuelles mais c'est un jeu vous lui
demander comment elle s'appelle première
solution vous lui faites un truc à vous
votre truc à vous vous cassez en
claquant la porte
moi j'y fais un truc à moi promet
ensuite je lui demande comment elle
s'appelle et finalement je me rendais à
leurs bras de bonnes réponses
alors imaginez c'est toujours une
position vous disparaissez dany aussi
mais bon attendons maintenant il
disparaît film hein c'est pas un truc
c'est inler c'est la rumeur c'est la
partie un peu solennel de l'hémicycle
est parti un peu hard
alors bon vous mourrez tous les deux
est-ce que vous préféreriez que noël
soit confiée à julien courbet belga
élevée par julien courbet une petite
bataille et fontaine dans ces violents
aussi hein y'a pas photo les animateurs
julien courbet bataille et fontaine où
christophe dechavanne rang de chaman way
dechavanne dechavanne
si les tournées lycos à nu ce jour des
gosses ouais si vous deviez mourir dans
un crash d'avion et rendez vous prévu
comme ça voilà sachant que tes gosses
sont élevés par julien combe bien cadre
est aussi dernières paroles avant de
décéder on mourait dans un crash d'avion
est ce que vous préféreriez un avion
d'air france d'egyptair ou de la varig
assez l'interview nul mais regardez pas
comme ça le principe de ce qu'est ce que
vous avez passé que je ne partais
raymond avions à bord pour la france
pour la famille halley à gonesse abbas
et pas plus
[Applaudissements]
alors
beaucoup plus à une bonne question est
ce que vous préféreriez être incarné ans
marguerite duras marilyn monroe ou
julien courbet marguerite duras ah bon
c'est son côté intello ça et quand on
est marine landrot on peut encore
apprendre mais quand on fait du race on
peut jamais devenir marilyn monroe quand
même une certaine façon elle a été
mariée monroe bon voilà on l'a pas vu ça
nous a bien échapper la façon dont elles
étaient marilyn
personne n'a remarqué c'est incroyable
qu'elle me détestez vous prononcez à
parcours des aides prononcer ouais le
mot qui n'arrivait pas à prononcer
conscient qu'avec ses rentes son pied ah
ça vous plaît pas ce nom vous dit
comment
avoir du plaisir on a fait un vieux nul
[Musique]
il a bougé non tout le monde était
parfait 3 qui hérite est exemplaire ah
ben moi je suis obligé de l'exemple
exemplaires est ce que vous préférez
votre père ou votre mère je préfère les
deux j'ai pas de choix
c'est dur à sa non venue j'ai dit que
c'est les questions vont ça oui mais il
n'y a pas de choix
c'est une question qu'on l'a mais j'en
étais sûr qu est ce que vous préférez
hitler ou staline dit pas les duels
alors c'est le coup de duclos la peste
ou le choléra c'est vrai je peux pas
choisir non plus c'est important vous
les mettez au même niveau je déteste les
deux voies là non parce que c'est qu'en
france il ya toujours des gens qui nous
explique que staline c'est mieux qu
hitler partez pas de ce principe là non
bien déjà pas mal vous devez partir sur
une île déserte
c'est un jeu de l'esprit et vous préféré
partir avec un tapis ou dominique
strauss kahn
alors il n'y a pas de y'a pas toi y'a
pas photo dominique strauss kahn pour
les cassettes est un ami oui j'assume
cette amitié complètement ça c'est un
bon côté vous avez les socialistes vous
c'est à dire que les mecs peuvent faire
les pires trucs vous les soutenez
toujours c'est votre côté me taire mon
ami non c'est mon ami et je sujet pas à
juger tel ou tel chose c'est mon ami
donc vous partez avec dominique strauss
kahn c'est jospin est mon ami c'est mon
ami d'accord voilà oui bien sûr il est
sympa il veut rebondir plus à thierry
après ce serait il se donne du mal là
pour avoir l'air sympa il a fait douze
pages dans gala j'aime bien quand vous
regardez comme ça
oui là je vais faire je ne sais pas si
tu as le regarde de claude allègre quand
tu me regardes et que j oublie c'est
comme ça quand tu lui dis une question
qui l'emmerdé la haute question qu'on
vous laver les cheveux tous les combien
tous les jours
un an presque trop bien parce que tu le
vaux bien
est ce que vous préférez un président de
la république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout pas d'élection du tout vous arrêtez
d'être démocratique à un moment quand ça
vous arrange plus vous arrêter d'être
démocrate dont vous me posez une
question humour est d'accord moi ça me
rappelle en algérie quand mes joues
pompe par le fils a failli gagner les
élections en algérie on arrêter le
processus des pauses vous me posez une
question je vous réponds dacca la merde
était bien est ce que ça dit son secours
merde et je peux même dire qu'ils aient
bataille qui est fontaine je vous
connaissais bataille et fontaine
je connais un joueur de foot qui
s'appelle fontaine juste fontaine bien
sûr que c'est autre chose c'est rendre
58 la sueur vous connaissez pas bataille
et fontaine non on préfère me dire
qu'est bataille qui est fontaine non
sarah est ce que pouvait me dire que les
batailles qui est fontaine
ce sont des comiques non ce sont des
présentations sur commis que d'une
certaine façon une campagne sans
présentateur sur tf1 y'a pas photo les
batailles qui est fontaine y en a un qui
est grand rien qu'un peu plus petit un
peu plus gros lequel est bataille le cas
les fontaines alors je crois que pascal
c'est le grand pascal qu'est bataille
n'essayez pas de m'embrouiller et
fontaine
sa fille linda cardiaque non mais ça
c'est une question interne de deux pas
du tout part de marché tous les lundis
soir catherine me dit que vous avez
raison vous savez que les batailles qui
est fontaine alors claude allègre est ce
que vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaire n'est supplément n'est
supplémentaires ou naïve supplémentaires
un doigt supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires j'aimerais avoir un oeil
supplémentaire derrière à toi tu as peur
de te remettre
il arrive et ministre en même temps
est-ce que vous préférez une femme qu'il
aime pas tellement faire d'amour [ __ ]
fidèles ou une femme qui adore faire
l'amour mais qui était un fidèle babala
deuxième bien sûr ah oui c'est bien
cette question les nouvelles je pense
pas que l'attesterait sur allègre mais
allait bien c'était à les constructions
de questions c'est vraiment une bonne
idée
vous préférez une femme qui aime faire
l'amour et au risque qu'elle soit
infidèle
oui au risque zéro risque et vous vous
préférez un garçon qui sait peut être
parce que vous pouvez espérer si vous
l'avez s'il vient combler qu'elle soit
enfin quand même fermé à gaz ou à la
merci de l'explication et vous vous
préférez un garçon qui sait pas très
bien faire l'amour mais qui est très
fidèle ou un garçon qui fait
merveilleusement l'amour un italien
génial et tout mais qui en même temps
voilà il court partout mais les italiens
sont souvent infidèles donc vous en
prenez votre parti même choix que moi et
c'est que la france entière se demande
quel est votre numéro de portable ça
relish taddert a pas bougé 1
elle est géniale pour une bourse c'est
dur
mignonne comme tout est bouché henry il
vient le moment où il va pouvoir se
barrer bien alors intervenu le vertus
sur des questions très con donc vous
pouvez répondre très connement comme
comme avons quoi qu'ils jugent comme
avant d'accord vous préférez votre père
ou votre mère ma mère par la force des
choses vous préférez hitler ou staline
dans la famille on n'a pas vraiment
apprécié hitler staline règles connues
par ouï dire oui alors vous partez trois
ans dans un vaisseau spatial c'est un
classique vous préféré partir alors avec
sarkozy que vous avez appelé le lapin
duracell s'est bien trouvés je vous
félicite c'est bien trouvé le lapin
duracell
quand vous partez avec sarkozy
douste-blazy ou françois hollande dans
un vaisseau spatial oui pendant trois
ans non moi je parte pas vous êtes
obligés de partir obligé de barbray
douste-blazy sarkozy ou françois
hollande
abidjan - drôle on sait jamais hollande
je connais pas ouais faut pas se tromper
est ce que vous trouvez plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des petites
[Rires]
un but qui staff des pics ou un jeune
qui tape sur les vieilles au premier 1
bah oui ça le droit un au revoir mais
vous préférez un président d'extrême
droite élu au suffrage universel ou pas
d'élection du tout ces [ __ ] universel
ah ouais ouais si vous ça ne peut pas
arriver si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex shop vous seriez quoi comme objet de
temps sachant que nous on l'aurait dans
le cul
[Applaudissements]
bustier quoique j'ai pas qu'est ce qu'on
vend des sex-shops on va encore dans
l'essex
il faut répondre williams nous étendons
dans un sex-shop vous êtes quoi pas de
langue de bois
il n'y a pas de langue de bois avec et
sans que j'ajoute un nom mais très
sincèrement à part des godemichés des
films je sais pas ce qu'on vend dans les
sex shops seraient godemiché donc je me
vois pas bien ce que tu disais voilà
être un film à moi tout seul donc ça
doit forcément l'autre l'autre faire
bryan michaud vous préférez une femme
alors ça c'est très important vous
préférez une femme une épouse une
maîtresse qui baisent mal etc et fidèle
winky baisse bien mais qu'un infidèle
c'est terrible c'est terrible mais c'est
que des questions très bon je me vois
faire la première à huy ouais mais si
vous préférez une femme qui bosse mâles
qui m'écrit fidèles ouais c'est bizarre
c'est pas du tout comme tu préfères quoi
toi il peut aller ailleurs c'est pas
c'est pas moi qu'on pose la question moi
je dois faire ce que je veux henry vous
préférez quoi vous pourquoi qui passe
mal et qu'ils aiment celle qui bossent
bien mais qu'elle a fidèlement et je
suis casé je sais pas vous poser la
question elle préfère un mec qui bosse
bien mais qu'un infidèle
le coût à salvador aurélie dupont
seniors alors attention weedon abitbol
vous vous concentrez s'il vous plaît oui
vous passeriez plus volontiers la nuit
avec anne sinclair à regarder des
cassettes en ce moment à vue libre oui
en ce moment là d'une temps avec anne
sinclair lors sinclair ou bob sinclair
[Rires]
lors sinclair l'ours en clair quand on
sait que c'est pour une ruse et la
profession que les anciens claire pagé
canal+ ouais vous seriez plus surpris si
on vous trouvez au lit avec un mec avec
deux filles un mec ah oui ça bouge ça
serait plus choquant pour vous bon sang
je serai sur moi surprise
c'est bien non anna ne bouge pas par le
jingle vous non plus rihanna sait bien
les filles bien alors attention c'est
compliqué c'est l'interview nul c'est la
main que vous préférez votre père votre
mère c'est nul j'avais versé nul
ouais mais je vous réponds les deux mon
général ça dépend des la nuit ma mère
qui est morte et le jour mon père qui
est en vie voilà vous préférez hitler ou
staline staline quand même pourquoi
parce qu'il a tué plus de gens non non
pour une eau non pour une vraie règle la
différence si vous voulez c'est que le
communisme est un rêve dramatiquement
avorter le nazisme n'a jamais eu une
part de rêve commise le communisme vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est un idéal des
voiliers ouais le nazisme n'épargnèrent
[Applaudissements]
le mot le mot le plus con en amour c'est
merci encore
oui oui je trouve que lewis est plus
ambivalent
alors vous préféreriez mourir comme john
lennon qui a été abattu par un coup de
revolver comme otis redding qui est mort
dans une chute dans un accident d'avion
un crash comme janis joplin qui est
morte d'une overdose ou comme bones
scott le chanteur décide ici qu'est il
s'est étouffé dans son vomi assas prix
original comme une bonne scott et non la
prochaine fois on verra un mac avec des
petites cornes comme ac/dc et puis un
short comme ambition si vous préféreriez
mourir tout de suite et aller au paradis
ou vivre encore 30 ans et leur d'enfer
en vivre encore 30 ans et aller en enfer
ça comme je crois nir paradis ni à
l'entraver regagner les transferts
d'accord vous vous laver les cheveux
tous les combien comme vous plus trois
fois par semaine pareil est ce que vous
préférez un président d'extrême droite
élu au suffrage universel ou pas
d'élection du tout pas d'élection du
tout ah ouais vous arrêtez donc le
président d'extrême droite et le
suffrage universel supprimera l'élection
au coup d'après ouais donc à tout
prendre c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
hitler c'est quand même ce qu'ils savent
c'est vrai qu'il perd alors acquis
confieriez-vous plus facilement vos
enfants si vous disparaissez sied à
maxime gremetz noël mamère ou jean louis
debré au avec maxime dereymez je suis
sûr qu'ils iraient à l'école et qu'ils
auraient de bonnes notes
si jamais vous retourner vers le
communisme quand même alors imagine est
une vue de l'esprit
vous rentrez chez vous vous trouvez
votre femme au lit avec rocco siffredi
c'est un jeu de l'esprit vous restez en
participant vous restez en boudant où
vous restez en vous pendant je médite
vous méritez mais dites vous partez pas
à jamais aucune situation voyez même à
votre question je pars pas tout dit
c'est à l'interview nul en ne bouge pas
pendant le dîner
[Applaudissements]
voilà les révolutionnaires risque c'est
bien alors soyez concentré jean claude
gayssot est ce que vous préférez celles
intervenues là je vous avertis vous
allez voir c'est très nul les questions
est ce que vous préférez votre père
votre mère difficile je suis partagé
peut-être ma mère c'est dur votre père
votre mère j'aimerais pas comme lacoste
drôlement merde
bah oui quoi je dirais qui tu répondes
j'ai beau tourner à perdre qu'eux mêmes
j'adore quand il dit qu'il va répondre à
des questions réponses il y en a eu des
mots n'arrivent
je vais répondre plus facilement vous
préférez staline hitler et attention si
vous aviez assez important ok ah ça
c'est nouveau nom jusqu'ici les
communistes disait staline quand même
d'être le premier communiste que je vois
répandant firmin pas je suis en bas mais
je vous assure c'est c'est tout ça tout
ce qu'on nous a mis à part peut-être
participer en apprenant c'est nous mêmes
peut être prêté à ce qu'on nous colle
cette idée qu'on était qu'on voulait
faire comme là bas quand vous qu'on
était porteur de ces crimes qu'ils ont
commis et tout ça peut-être là dans
notre façon d'être de les défendre parce
qu'il y avait là le méchant loup
américaine qu'il fallait tout ça ça a dû
exister d'ailleurs y'a pas que y'a pas
que les communistes
bref en tout cas aucun cas je peux vous
dire que le communisme tel que nous le
concevons aujourd'hui la rien à voir
n'est bien sûr avec khider l'a combattu
à mieux parti des fusillés
c'est les communistes bon à partir de 41
g jean claude blanc maintenant d'elle
tout cas les biens dit penser à du
talent partie décisive est obligé de
vous parler du pacte germano-soviétique
oui les et de passionnés c'est pas
terrible pacte germano-soviétique que
l'epu est compris à ce moment là le
soutenir je ne suis pas fier de cela non
ben je vous le dis alors à qui trouvez
vous le plus de circonstances
atténuantes un vieux qui se tape des
jeunes moins jeunes qui tapent sur des
vieux un vieux qui se tape des jeunes
comme votre femme est là un levier qui
se tape déjà plus de cinq ans en
s'atténuant why we un ami débarque chez
vous la nuit à l'improviste il rentre il
s'approche de la table de nuit
vous dormez votre femme dort qu'est-ce
qui vous gênerait le plus qu'ils
trouvent sur la table de chevet un
godemichet ou miles kane
mike aof alors attention jean claude
gayssot est ce que vous accepteriez de
mourir comme ça subitement là maintenant
si cela devait éradiquer pour toujours
la pauvreté sur la terre si ça se devait
oui ouais mais comme je suis sûr comme
jeudi la journée c'est l'esprit sur vous
n'y aura plus jamais de peau vous allez
mourir n'y aura plus jamais de pauvres
sur la terre oui oui peut-être oui
question compliquée on est tous les deux
dans un chalet c'est l'hiver on est sous
la neige
on a bouffé moi je meurs de froid et de
manger rien à manger tellement il fait
froid et pour survivre êtes obligé de me
manger vous commencez par quelles
parties de mon corps
j'élimine tout ce qui risque d'amener la
le sud comment s'appellent les prions de
la dame est criant ouais non vous fait
pas le viseur linge que les muscles
je touche pas tu as colonne vertébrale
très bien hâte à moi les attend cerveau
par colas et avant lui pas le bon j'ai
un cerveau deux monarchistes vous allez
vous employez mais attention bien
alors attention à la c'est votre
entourage m'a demandé de pas vous parler
de vos origines turques un entendez ça
c'est une petite fiche de balladur je
vous seriez plus gêné d'être surpris par
jacob donc au lit avec deux filles ou un
mec plus gênés avec deux filles avec un
mec ce nom parce qu'un mec c'est pas
possible
ouais avec la carrure saviez-vous qu'il
savait pas ce que je fais mais je
commence à m
les trois minutes
dernière question la plus contre tout si
vous étiez en vente dans un sex-shop
vous seriez quoi vous savez ce que c'est
qu'une branlette
oui c'est vrai une branlette oui c'est
la partie médiane de la canne à pêche
annonce et saliha je crois beaucoup dans
une canne à pêche et la partie médiane
s'appelle la branlette les personnes je
le dire parce qu'il parle ce congrès
bouchon trop loin on est d'accord on
vous seriez une branlette voilà
[Musique]
alors vous partez sur une île déserte
vous préférez une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau je préfère une fille puis
même l'aide
ah ouais ah oui d'accord c'est un vrai
terreau jean marie messier est un vrai
terreau mais la mesa del entation
circonstances atténuantes vous donner le
plus de circonstances atténuantes un
vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles un
vieux qui se trame du petit vous
préparer pour hollywood la non mais
l'autre bien alors un ami arrive chez
vous à l'improviste en pleine nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus ce
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de nuit
c'est que j'ai fait appel à du recel a
imaginé et loire un ami arrive à
l'improviste chez vous sur la table de
nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus bête
le plus qui trouve mein kampf ou un
godemiché mein kampf
ben quoi balladur mein kampf aussi mais
c'est ce que c'est qu'un god incroyable
bien sûr qu'il sera turquie devant tous
okapi à me lâcher un petit c'est
lamentable bien alors est-ce que vous
échangeriez une paralysie générale si
vous êtes tétraplégique pour le restant
de vos jours contre la faim de la famine
au bangladesh le chichi par nat
je dis oui si je suis honnête on sait
bien que non est ce que vous êtes un
ambitieux qui a ramé ou un opportuniste
qui a eu de la chance j'ai un ambitieux
quai de la chance à bord on part en
vacances tous les deux dans la montagne
il fait très froid il ya beaucoup de mal
j'ai trois mètres de neige on peut pas
aller faire les courses je meurs on
n'avait plus rien à manger vous me
manger vous commencez par quoi partie
bien dodues le gros cube d'accord donc
préféré jean marie messier veut bouffer
le cueilleur d'essaim par des
périphrases prise par l'eau mais aussi
le lien dans les collèges le curé qu'est
ce que tu veux c 501 et ça se sent
toujours dernière question jean marie
mais si vous vous laver les cheveux tous
les combien toujours tous les deux jours
où jean marie messier
6ème points comme chf littérature j
achète on vend ses biens
à la une qui va faire du cinéma à
hollywood dans pas longtemps hein
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bougé merde à cause de toi aussi je
bouge bien est ce que vous préférez
votre père ou votre mère jeanne avertir
c'est pas possible je pars à son
intérieur
ben je peux pas je vois monseigneur di
falco qui attend là-bas rassurez vous
monseigneur cette interview on l'a fait
à samuel le bihan donc vous y avez
échappé defacto alors plus simple est ce
que vous préférez staline ou hitler
j'ai envie de dire staline mais c'est
pourquoi il a tué plus de gens quittent
l'air voilà et puis c'est ça un peu plus
plus méconnu c'est un peu moins proche
comme est d'accord oui les gens sont
moins informés du goût lac dès que de
jeunes s'éloignent
alors ça c'est déjà plus simple vous
êtes trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial
est ce que vous préférez partir avec kad
et o ù bataille et fontaine trop fort tu
dis ce que tu veux on n'en voudra pas ce
que tu vas venir à voir le film
je connais un peu plus j'ai déjà vu
leurs émissions et voilà ça me fait
marrer vocale et aux gentils bonne
bourre les mecs qui a les pattes entre
nous ah non pas du tout was the state a
en effet mis fin dans la nuit
bien alors vous partez de partir s'il me
passe la pièce dans votre émission sur
dix sont le pain sa quéquette c'est pas
trop service public c'est quand même un
alors [ __ ] vous partez sur une île
déserte
si vous partez sur une île déserte
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec un
mec très beau ou une fille très laide
fille très laide vous n'êtes pas [ __ ] du
tout vos mais pas du tout ouais
désolé mais non merci j'ai jamais vu ça
quand même préféré préfet mais il
préfère une fille très lettre qu'un mec
très beau un bep de cette façon au bout
deux jours je trouve un très bel donc
[Applaudissements]
elle il est tout petit j'ai oublié de
dire y'a pas on peut pas se planquer 1
est-ce que vous accordez plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles c'est quel âge
les petites 14 ans à 14 ans est rude
mais je préfère celui qui tape les
vieilles rappel des conteneurs
bon vote punition préféré c'est être
peint ces mordus ou piqué a mordu j'aime
bien le mot le plus quand en amour c'est
merci encore oui oui savait pas dans
quelle langue
arias merci ctreq merci c'est en tant qu
on n'a rien foutu remercie alors samuel
si vous aviez un perroquet mais j'ai
bousillé un perroquet voulu apprendriez
quoi comme phrase tu à fermer le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco
j'avais averti jeudi que son final
dernier un bien être si utiles les
perroquets ah oui ça c'est terrible à
vous trouvez votre fiancée au lit avec
depardieu
ça c'est chiant question qu'est ce que
vous faites
ryle éclate vous restez qu'est ce que
vous faites alors
vous restez bien vous mettez au lit avec
eux et je regarde on vous regarde et oui
vous gifle et votre fiancée vous boudez
vous tuer vous parler boulot 6e de mise
depardieu
il
catherine me dit c'est vrai catherine sa
productrice de l'émission elle dit pour
un mec l'epa pdc dominent facilement
depardieu est bien vu catherine
bienvenus dès que divalto et laure
noualhat samuel le bihan combien
puis-je du pacte des loups de christophe
qui sort le 31 janvier
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas par le
jingle oui je ne me ferai pas le sait
comment le sait on ne touche pas pendant
le finger bien c'est l'interview nul oui
vous préférez steyn ou hitler ni l'un ni
l'autre je déteste le stalinisme et
l'hitlérisme et le fascisme c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut combattre toute
sa vie préféré à l'indolence jean paul
belmondo et ben écoutez je ne dis pas
devant son fils j'adore adan de long
même si on pense pas tout à fait la même
chose et la première fois que j'ai vu
c'était pour les 10 ans tf1 75 à la tour
eiffel c'est mourousi qui me l'a
présenté mais tomber dans les bras et il
m'a dit tu sais je t'aime bien
et depuis on est devenus amis et aux del
mondo je le connais mais je n'ai pas les
mêmes liens qu avec alain delon oui des
gens qui aiment votre père heureusement
bien vous partez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial président oui vous
préféré partir avec etienne mougeotte
marc tessier patron de france
télévisions où pierre lescure sophie
marceau vous croisez un extraterrestre à
matin d'aller acheter des cigarettes
extra terreste vous êtes qui vous et
vous connais évidemment vous ne répondez
quoi je suis avec bourges
ah ouais il suffit pour ça que j'ai
extraterrestre ce n'est pas ça qui est
important
n'hésite pas je suis un terrien passion
il passe son chemin et moi le mien et je
suis un humain je suis un terrien riche
hervé bourmaud des bras qui vous êtes je
suis reebok en cas d'accord bien avec
retiens ça c'est un email de jim pour
envoyer des emails pour des questions ça
s'est compliqué avec quel pays la france
a la plus grande frontière
si j'étais vaches dire avec la belgique
mais c'est pas le cas grâce te ment la
série à le brésil bravo à cause de la
guyane par les accords
tout à fait vous voyez fut nulle si vous
étiez en vente dans un sex-shop vous
seriez quoi je ne crois que je ne serai
jamais en vendant un sex-shop mais parce
que je ne suis pas suffisamment attirant
ah ah qu'est le sport le plus combo le
football américain
aulas ben voilà amérique vous défendez
plus mon équipe de football américain
alors expliquez vous restez bien assis
très sexy comme le sport les uniformes
sont fantastiques
c'est devenu un petit peu plus que
maintenant parce qu'il ya trop de
publicité et lv1 30 ans c'était quelque
chose d'un ordinaire le c'est comme le
sport le foot ici en europe des cons
commercialisons il perd son mystère
alors si vous deviez partir sur une île
déserte ou partiriez avec un mec très
beau une fille très laide ni l'inde ni
lui ni le bas tant que c'est pas attiré
par les hommes mais je n'ai pas les
filles moches mais non nous on a une qui
s'appelle mina si tu nous regardes nina
me nadji moi chaque fois qu'un acteur ou
quelqu'un qui veut partir avec une fille
mais je suis d'accord
voilà ce que samuel le bihan par exemple
il disait moi je préfère partir avec une
film j'ai reçu d'accord elle quand elle
a vu samuel le bihan va bien si vous
deviez mourir présidence de l'accident
d'avion vous préféreriez que ce soit air
france va rigoler giltaire mais
strictement égal si je dois mourir peu
importe la compagnie avant l'état
nationaliste vous préfériez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion comme
john lennon d'un dash hot comme bones
scott le chanteur décide ici que s'est
étouffé dans son vomi nous comme janis
joplin qui est morte d'une overdose
non rires dans son vomi s'attendent la
tour d'argent non il ya longtemps que
j'ai pu à la tour d'argent c'est un
bordel là
le canard au sang était pas mal mais
c'est plus ce que c'était dingue et qui
seul c'est un peu chichiteux est-ce que
vous accordez plus de circonstances
atténuantes un vieux qui se tape des
jeunes où un jeune qui tapent sur des
vieux j'aime pas les jeunes qui tapent
sur des vieux bois je préfère un vieux
qui se tape une jeune fille était
consentante bien alors là c'est sérieux
on est tous les deux bloqués dans un
chalet oui la 4 mètres de neige
oui je meurs de faim oui et pour pas
mourir de faim vous me manger vous
commencez par quoi réside en fait vous
le dire par l'oreille aux parce que
quand je vais au restaurant quelques
fois j'adore manger les oreilles de
cochon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et j'ai pas ajouter et parce que le
placer les oreilles et la queue de
cochon et que ça fait attention
président qu'est ce que ferait le plus
plaisir maintenant oui moi de vivre
c'est un bonheur formidable d'être
libres d'être aujourd'hui
d'un autre côté j'étais dans le xvème
oui où il ya des tours etc
j'avais un bureau splendide j'avais de
vue sur la tour surtout paris et puis un
poème d'apollinaire sur le pont mirabeau
maintenant je suis dans 9e du côté de la
rue long march est formidable c'est
plein de riches trop où il ya une vie
dacquois comme bas nationaux moi j'ai
pas de bagnole non j'en avais eu une
avarie et mes collègues m'ont offert en
partant une carte orange couvre le métro
sur ces mots je découvre pas je connais
j'ai pris le métro dans mon enfance dans
ma jeunesse beaucoup c'est vrai disons
le ce a fait une vingtaine d'années que
j'ai pris le métro via padova ce qu'il y
avait dans l'audiovisuel exe toujours
été à des postes de responsabilité qu
une voiture et un chauffeur
mais je reprends le métro avec un
plaisir formidable même vous dire que
l'autre jour j'étais à une réunion du
quai d'orsay et j'ai pris le métro à à
l'assemblée nationale direction porte de
la chapelle
c'est là où j'ai changé j'ai pris
créteil pour descendre un grand
boulevard est allé
la bombe sur scène
[Musique]